good morning Hank it's Sunday bonus
videos so an opinion poll last week
found that more than 20% of Americans
believe that the President of the United
States Barack Obama is a Muslim
now Obama has repeatedly said that he is
a Christian but he also repeatedly said
he'd allow us to import prescription
drugs from Canada and that hasn't
happened so instead of taking Obama's
word that he is not a Muslim I thought
today we could do an analysis of what we
know about Barack Obama and what we know
about Islam and come to our own
conclusions so the five most central
facets of Islamic belief in practice are
known as the five pillars of Islam the
first is the Shahada the recitation and
belief in the statement that there is no
deity other than God and that Muhammad
is God's prophet you're not a Muslim
until you say and believe the Shahada
now we can't prove the president Obama
has ever said the Shahada but we also
can't prove that he hasn't said it so
let's move on the second pillar is
prayer now as many of us know observant
Muslims pray at least five times a day
dawn noon mid afternoon sunset and
nighttime and it just so happens that we
know a lot about Barack Obama's daily
schedule because he's the president so
for instance we know that on April 8
2010 during evening prayers Obama was
having dinner with Dmitri Medvedev who
you will be surprised to learn did not
emerge from that dinner saying oh my god
Barack Obama pulled out a prayer rug
turned it in the direction of the Kaaba
and proceeded to pray we also know that
on April 5th 2010 during noon prayers
Barack Obama was hosting the White House
Easter egg hunt nobody at that event
noted Barack Obama prostrate on the
ground praying in Arabic the third
pillar of Islam is a cot the cicadas
almsgiving Muslims are required to give
2.5 percent of their wealth every year
to the poor the public has access to a
lot of Obama's tax returns in between
2000 and 2005 he and Michelle gave an
average of less than 1% of their income
to charity
meaning that in addition to being a bit
of a tightwad Barack Obama was not
performing zakat the fourth pillar is
Psalm or fasting during the holy month
of Ramadan Muslims do not eat or drink
between dawn and dusk Ramadan began this
year on August 11th on August 17th a
photographer snapped this picture of
Barack Obama ordering lunch which he
proceeded to eat in front of hundreds of
people in fact the president has been
seen eating and drinking during the day
pretty much every single day of Ramadan
the fifth pillar is Hajj or pilgrimage
Muslims who can afford to do so and are
able-bodied are obligated to make the
pilgrimage to Mecca at least once in
their lives Obama has not yet
made this trip although there's still
time but it's unlikely he ever will for
this reason the Saudi government will
not let you into Mecca if you are not a
Muslim and Barack Obama is not a Muslim
so it was possible that Barack Obama has
said Shahada at some private moment that
we don't know about he completely and
spectacularly fails to follow any of the
other four pillars of Islam so we don't
even have to get into the fact that he
drinks beer and eats pork hotdogs
humorously this leads one of two
possibilities Hank either President
Obama is not a Muslim or he is a really
bad Muslim of course there's nothing
wrong with being a Muslim president
Obama just isn't one he's also not
Jewish not a baby and not the starting
left fielder for the New York Yankees
so Drudge Report Huffington Post CNN Fox
News maybe we can find something else to
talk about Hank I'll see you tomorrow
oh and PS this suit it isn't all
business